first of all congratulations a dominant
performance in today's rounds how did
you come
to how did you approach today's rounds
yeah i mean you just try to approach it
where you play chess i mean it really
could not have gone worse than it did
for me the rapid portion so just tried
to play play good chess i mean i think
really the main thing though is when
when you aren't playing well you just
want to get off to a good start and uh
with the two whites of start if i if i
didn't win like one or both of those
games i think it could have been a long
day but fortunately i did and the rest
was was pretty smooth i mean in a way i
wish i had won this game against john
but at the same time i also should have
lost lenie so sort of offsets you also
uh brought a superpower in today's
rounds the pineapple shirt tell us a bit
about the story behind that yeah i mean
that's i guess already a couple years
ago now in 2020 when i was streaming um
and many of many of the streams i was
doing i was wearing the pineapple shirt
it became this meme from this famous
streamer forson's chat and it's kind of
stuck stuck with me and then i've just
you know taken advantage of it since
then but it you know it's a side thing
but it wasn't it didn't play a huge role
in my success today i'll say that at the
beginning of today's rounds did you
harbor any hopes of potentially winning
the tournament or was that in the back
of your mind yeah i mean i think uh it's
happened in a couple of grand chester
events where players have been way
behind after the rap and they score they
have a really big score i don't think
they've ever come back to win i mean it
would be pretty amazing from last to
first um
that wasn't really in my mind i mean i
think if the leaders stumble they
stumble but i i just wanted to play good
shots because i felt that much of the um
many of the issues in the rapid were
self-inflicted i mean i found a way to
lose a couple of games that i definitely
should never have lost um fabiano game
was was was of course really really poor
even at the end um but yes played good
chess and things seemed to go my way for
the most part i mean i thought it was
very smooth only the game against lenie
was sort of up and down but otherwise i
i had great positions and i mean again
when you do so poorly in the rapid it
doesn't get worse so i just tried to
play my best you dominated uh today's
rounds but also the leader ali reza
filja has had a fantastic day how do you
assess his performance yeah i mean what
he got seven so obviously that's a very
good score um
yeah i mean he's he played well in the
rap and he's playing well on the blitz
and i think actually getting back to my
own result that's why i was so so
annoyed about about this game against um
fabiano and also sam for that matter
because the thing is no one's running
away with running away with the event so
it's very very bunched up and and if you
just can put points on the board and
then give yourself give yourself a
chance in the blitz anything can happen
um
so that's why i was annoyed but yeah for
ali reza obviously he's having a great
event both in the rapid and the blitz
and i mean he's a deserved leader right
now so we'll see what happens tomorrow
hikaru still nine runs to go get some
rest we'll see you tomorrow thank you
well played sir well done icaru